la russe appelle ukraine et elle mène
tout droit vers la frontière à moins de
deux kilomètres la russie prend fin ici
il n'y a pas de soldats ni de chars en
vue mais beaucoup beaucoup de
va-et-vient
bladimir et son fils sont venus de
lougansk le plus proche des deux
territoires séparatistes de l'ukraine
pour faire le plein de denrées ils ont
un passeport russe maintenant mais il
clame haut et fort leur indépendance
à louga en finale ont attaqué personne
t-il la gorge nouée nous ne voulons
qu'une chose c'est vivre en paix à côté
guéniat n'en demande pas plus elle aussi
de passage pour quelques heures en
russie le temps de ramasser un colicci
zara et de faire quelques emplettes avec
son ami parce que de leur côté c'est
cher et il n'y a plus grand chose à
jeter les russes elle est initiée à
l'ukrainienne et appréhendent une autre
guerre l'autre tranche honte une phrase
je suis terrifiée dit-elle en 2014 et en
cavale pendant des mois pour échapper
aux combats avec mes enfants et j'ai
tellement peur que ça recommence même si
elle n'a aucune idée de l'ampleur du
déploiement russes ou des intentions
exactes du kremlin des villes comme
celle ci sur la frontière avec l'ukraine
y en a des centaines
et même si on sait que les troupes sont
là elles sont en retrait leçon à des
centaines de kilomètres au nord à
voronej au sud à rostov sur le don on
peut pas s'en approcher on peut pas les
filmer et pour les gens qui habitent la
région l'idée d'une attaque est tout
simplement impensable au
cursus que lucho des soldats j'en vois
pas j'en entends pas du bien dit mir qui
vit à 800 m de l'ukraine youtube 12 12
c'est un complot de l'occident et de
l'otan pour nous diviser de nos freins
craignent le la comme tant d'autres
russe il croit que son pays n'est
menacée vous aviez votre commentaire
nous ça sur mon disque
naisseline croyais aussi plus à dire
poutine a raison d'exiger que l'ukraine
soit exclu le temps à tout jamais les
chefs des cosaques de la région les plus
patriotiques de paix mais pitié dit-il
patte d'oie
laissons le crâne traquer les allemands
sont mostar slave et que dieu leur donne
la tête mais si la russie attaque comme
le craint de plus en plus l'amérique si
la guerre éclate peu importe qui la
provoque l'italie dit qu'il se battra
aux côtés des russes racines
mais la plupart d'un côté comme de
l'autre de la frontière n'y crois pas ou
encore préfèrent tout simplement on ne
peut pas y penser et si thammarat
altérait secoue radio canada dans la
région de rostov en russie